il est 11h30 au centre ville de montréal
les travailleurs quittent le chantier en
hauteur sur les nouveaux condos pour
aller dîner non pas au comptoir de fast
food mais bien dans une épicerie provigo
pourquoi les clients sont aussi
intéressés à venir alors du launch
magazine et à l'épicerie pour aller dans
un restaurant mais je crois
personnellement que c'est pour le prix
pour la rapidité aussi service pour vous
c'est déjà tout prêts dont ils n'ont pas
besoin d'attendre que la cuisine y
concocte pour la grèce nous c'est déjà
préparé et l'éditrice et plus pratique
et plus rapide même que le restaurant
oui tout à fait s'il ya des caisses luc
service ya les caisses normal donc c'est
sûr que ça va passer rapidement cinq
minutes péter d'or
ces prêts tout prêts tout frais ou
encore gravé ngo c'est le nouveau jargon
du prêt-à-manger une tendance qui
bouleversent le monde de l'alimentation
ça c'est intéressant parce qu on assiste
à une confusion des genres le restaurant
rampe en alimentation
puis le magasin d'alimentation commence
à rentrer dans le restaurant mais n'a le
prêt-à-manger lui-même évolué évoluer
dans ce format évoluer dans la diversité
mais surtout évolué dans la qualité hors
du prêt-à-manger ici on retourne aux
années 50 mais c'est telle était l'idée
nous vient d'un comptoir ici est
derrière moi on a environ 40 de
recherche qu'on peut offrir aux clients
saas et apprendra le font des reproches
au camp ça vous servez chaud
le prg et à manger et entrée de
transformer les épiceries il occupe
maintenant 25 % de l'espace au plancher
est-ce que stratégiquement c'est quand
warner sont situés à un endroit précis à
lippi oui ça c'est sûr ils sont
généralement situés à l'entrée ce que
veut pas dire que les gens vont aller
prendre à nantes ils peuvent très bien
les prendre en sorte mais une chose est
sûre c'est qu'ils vont les voir et ils
vont les sentir deux fois
on veut gagner du temps pour le souper
également donc ils m'ont passé avant le
retour à la maison maman c'est un peu
concoctée par vos chefs mais ça ne me
convient c'est pepsi avait la famille
dont les jambes tellement que sa suite
le prêt-à-manger ces dépliants qui
comprenait le jour après jour tu peux
revenir dans la semaine cinq fois dans
la semaine
ici se figer à express propose une
version simplifiée des grandes surfaces
ces épiceries nouvelle jouxte est
immanquablement des tours à condos tout
neuf verticaux est minuscule
selon statistique canada 28 % des foyers
canadiens sont occupés par une seule
personne
on sait bien des enquêtes ont montré que
les personnes qui habitent seules n'ont
pas envie de cuisiner et parmi les
personnes qui habitent seuls il n'ya pas
uniquement des personnes âgées il ya
aussi des personnes jeunes ou parfois il
ya même des couples chacun chez soi des
personnes plus âgées qui vivent plus
longtemps a pas de santé mais qui on
perd de vue l'intérêt à cuisiner et puis
à l'imprimé il ya tous ces millénaire
you qui manque de tact tellement
d'autres choses à faire ma vie que de
cuisiner armes étaient ces deux segments
leur ensemble
vous venez de toucher à peu près 60%
maintenant de la population la grande
tablée à tous les soirs avec quatre
enfants autour de papa maman s'est rendu
aux autorités
on observe aussi que il y a comme un
rajeunissement de la population
ce rajeunissement est due à la fois à
l'immigration car nous attirons
des généraux ce sont des personnes qui
ont joué un rôle capital dans la
diversification de l'alimentation
on s'est mis à prendre l'habitude de
manger de plus en plus de choses
différentes et on n'a pas nécessairement
les talons pour faire toutes ces
cultures culinaires différentes
[Musique]
bienvenue d'un good tarn au lieu de
jeunesse étudiante du professionnel
montréalaise et a tellement de fois que
c'est presqu'à la star et manque juste
le service à table
ici chez adonis on prépare chaque jour
des plats pour une clientèle curieuse et
très diversifié qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent
manger un peu de trop ils veulent
toujours essayer quelque chose de
nouveau c'est sûr qu'on a cette tendance
qu'ils vont vers ce qui est santé mais
ils veulent essayer de tout
comme nous on a ici à peu près une
dizaine de fois par jour fait qu'ils
veulent toujours essayer quelque chose
de nouveau
ce qui est intéressant c'est de voir que
ce qui est testé maintenant où ce qui
est développé en 30 urbain
progressivement commence à rayonner dans
la première ou la deuxième couronne
périphériques des grandes villes j'ai
dit midi au tout nouveau avril de laval
ont fait la queue pour venir dîner dans
la salle à manger de l'épicerie c'est la
porte d'entrée pour faire connaître
après le mobilier moderne espace
lumineux
on se croirait dans un café de musée
pourtant nous sommes à quelques pas des
élites traditionnelles d'une épicerie
grandes surfaces on à la boulangerie
fromage
rooney jo le pizzaïolo qui paie de la
pizza minute deux minutes qui est
excellente donc là les gens peuvent
venir chercher le nom c'est ce pôle tes
quant à la pizzeria mais celui un petit
2 avril emploi toute une brigade pour
récupérer en cuisine les fruits et
légumes de l'épicerie qu'ils revendent
ensuite avec une marge de profit
beaucoup plus intéressante qu'avec les
produits en tablette tout en réduisant
le gaspillage alimentaire
mais qu'est ce qui fait que ça a changé
à ce point là oui mais vraiment les gens
veulent bien manger donc en voulant bien
mangé ça la force et les épices fille à
femme du prêt-à-manger a à proposer
quelque chose de meilleur qu'au
restaurant pour un meilleur coup à la
chaîne et vous lèverez sensible plus
cher si vous le préparez vous même un
peu mais le jeune j'ai connu une bonne
pratique donc pour un rapport
économisant l'eau si c est vraiment dame
on n'a pas fini d'entendre parler du
prêt-à-manger au fur et à mesure où le
temps évolue
vous allez voir dans toutes les
épiceries la partie conventionnelle de
l'épicerie perdre de l'espace pour une
raison bien simple c'est que c'est les
produits qu'on y retrouve alors le
papier hygiénique les pâtes alimentaires
sont des produits qui progressivement
vont prendre le chemin du web se faisant
cet espace là qui est dévolue aux
produits conventionnels votre diminué au
cours des prochaines années
ceux qui vont augmenter c'est ce que
vous voyez
[Musique]